I remember like a few years ago it was
like like there was stories about you
like crazy stuff and I remember getting
the impression like man it seems like TJ
Miller is in trouble with alcohol or
something like that and uh I was like I
remember feeling like concerned for you
and then that concerns kind of like went
away because there hasn't been any
stories like that well and what's
interesting and I'm I want to talk about
this probably in March
but I have a brain condition and I just
oh that's right we hadn't you had brain
surgery I had brain surgery and they
took out a golf ball sized piece of my
brain and it was from my right frontal
lobe
and I was born with an AVM which is an
arterial venous malformation and it's
just a malformed part of your brain that
never really develops it's just a mess
of arteries and veins
that you don't use but it is
um
it's prone to hemorrhaging it's like
more fragile than the rest of your brain
but what's weird and again I just didn't
talk about this for a long time because
I didn't want to make it a part of my
identity I guess was the reason I didn't
or I didn't want to be honest with
myself that I was brain damaged or as my
neuropsychologist says I had a traumatic
brain injury
um do you know what the injury was so it
wasn't you're born with it okay so yeah
Birds was the entry the worst of all
because you never recover from it right
um and so
um and so I what happens with the brain
is because I don't have the same amount
of brain matter as the two of you the
rest is the elasticity of the brain it's
such an amazing organ
um
all the other parts of my brain picked
up slack and so I seem act and think as
if I'm a regular person like right now
you got but what's different is I'm
prone to Mania and so
um what somebody who is bipolar feels I
don't feel the depression side of that
but I can tip my way into the Mania
do you get manic at all yeah sometimes
and when I do it's [ __ ] creepy as
hell dude it's crazy and so do you know
what is happening
um it's hard to tell until you're in it
and then when you're in it it's you're
so far gone that you're just like yeah
this is amazing my mind has reached a
different this is the greatest City I've
ever had in my life 100 I'm gonna start
I'm gonna work on the computer while I'm
doing this thing I'm gonna be uh no I
gotta write I gotta write so then you
write like 50 pages 100 pages and then
you stop you're like okay I'll get back
to this oh I gotta be making food while
I'm doing it's just it's so I've never
done cocaine but people say it's like
that but it's not because because you're
not on drugs there's no way for you to
be like maybe it's the drugs
I had a like a surgery recently the one
that I said that was the highest I've
been like that yeah I just saw that
video that that triggered some crazy
Mania in me like you weren't I didn't
see I've seen it other size before and I
I you were [ __ ] up but it wasn't like
I think it was just no sleep [ __ ] up
like I didn't see anything wow about it
so that's the big thing and this is what
you heard and and said which is like
something where you're on a train or
something so I had a manic episode on
the train and what happens is because of
my condition I have to get eight or nine
hours of sleep a night oh wow if I don't
sleep for an entire night it's very
dangerous and the other thing that's
dangerous is combination so five hours
of sleep having a bunch of drinks
being dehydrated right smoking pot
that's too strong keeps me up I only get
three hours of sleep then all those
things can kind of I start to get my
feet in Mania and what I've talked to my
neuropsychologist about recently like in
the last week or two is that I have to
just be honest with myself that Mania is
fun it can be fun and so it's sort of
addictive in that way where you're like
maybe I'll have another shot and just
stay up a little bit longer and see if I
could just just get there and then it's
like and then he goes goes goes goes
Mania is your drug of choice kind of yes
and the way to get there is lack of
sleep
um also if you have extreme
um emotional swings things that are
happening like that that can also
trigger it and that's what happened on
the train is that I had been going I had
been totally Sleepless I had this whole
situation where
this uh you know it's just I I had the
internet absolutely attacking me and I
had it feeling like the world so I was
gonna spin out no matter what and the
problem is the way that I spin out used
to be like this I'm sure also was to
kind of turn to drugs and alcohol to
kind of mollify that like ah and that
instead of like making me be like hold
on gasoline on the fire and and so then
what happened was item manic episode on
the train there
I sort of believed that this woman was
dangerous and which translates to other
like well women can be dangerous and
women that you don't know can do awful
things and all this kind of so that was
all in my brain and
um and then I thought New Yorker I'm
very proud of living in New York City I
was like well if you see something say
something so I want to be a good New
Yorker and so I saw something I said
something and I want to let you guys
know if it's not anything it'll be
something okay oh it'll be saying for a
while it'll be everything uh but that in
my mind it was all real it's all real
that I'm hoping that this woman deserves
that we've call this out and make sure
that she's not being dangerous and all
this stuff
and so it was a misunderstanding with
the federal government they eventually
dismissed it because they understood for
sure they're like okay if this is where
he can get to I had evaluations by all
these doctors but what it did was great
is I found this neuropsychologist who
explained to me you had this surgery in
2010 and they didn't have the thing that
you needed it didn't exist then what I
needed was called cognitive remediation
and it's where you go back and you teach
yourself to do the things that other
people do cognitively
um without thinking about it down
regulate I don't know what is that it's
just like talking yourself down in a
healthy manner
I mean I know we haven't used that like
like I don't I don't have it like if I
get frustrated I'm just like oh and I
had like normal people are just like
okay cool it's not that big of a deal
but I don't have that there would be
that it's also things like looking at
your schedule for the next day
or like
um
what are some other examples of it just
like like looking at me this is all real
looking in the mirror and seeing do I
have physical signs of being tired
because I never feel tired oh my God I
feel tired of time he's like I'm always
[ __ ] tired it's the worst it's the
second worst I don't have that and so
never will I be like and so that's why
I'm kind of this Indie fatigueable just
never exhausted work ethic that I just
constantly and it's driven also by
wanting to make people feel good wanting
to make them laugh because I think life
is so [ __ ] tragic you know from
almost every angle sure and so and we
know the reason I like circus because no
matter what you're doing you tune into
something Stevo's doing right now and
you're like everything's gone you're
just like is he going to die type thing
yeah and and also you know when you're a
great Storyteller a person just lets
everything go and sits in the story if
you've got a joke that's gonna make so I
love doing that so much and so I just
thought well I should just work as hard
as I can until I die Ai and I had to
sort of learn not to do that so that's
that that's been really helpful for me
because now I recognize it I can tell
and yeah
like it's been a long time since like
that any of that has been in the
Consciousness oh yeah right like uh yeah
I think so and I think the other thing
is is that um it's a shame that I didn't
have a forum then to talk about mental
illness and it's also it's not just
mental illness it's like brain damage
you know and what that can leave you
with when you're trying to figure it out
isn't that funny are you brain damaged
at all ah not that I'm aware of see I
would like I like to be the women you
would think it would be the absolute
opposite that he would be brain damaged
and I wouldn't well right well now like
with the CT thing they can't find out if
you have it until you're dead and they
like can look at your brain so I mean
I'm a little bit of a question mark in
that regard yeah well and the nitrous
oxide was completely because it was a
Slowdown I would never do cocaine or
amphetamines or anything like that
because I don't need to go that
direction I don't drink coffee I don't
do any of that stuff
um but nitrous was so effective at
bringing it down so I was probably in a
manic State when I hosted the Critics
Choice Awards the second one and so to
sort of bring that Mania down I would do
nitrous because then it would be gone
because drinking that is depressed and
it works but you can't become undrunk
like right 15 minutes later did you ever
start hearing voices when you're doing
nitrous a little bit they're like The
psychosis yeah because they're it can
get pretty bad when I stopped was when
because you do build a tolerance for it
yeah I stopped when I was like this just
isn't it's not bringing me down enough
right but it still like gives you a
headaches or it's crazy well you did it
for a long time I did a lot of it man I
did a lot of it and it really messed me
up I think what there's a like a study
done by the voices in your head uh per
like based on the continent you're from
like the psychosis some some countries
are like a woman's voice some countries
are a men's voice
like I had a whole committee did you
really yeah you like thinking maybe did
more of it I'm surprised you don't have
nerve damage that was another problem
but um I yeah I would hear sort of Echo
and then realize it's not my voice
that's pretty [ __ ] scary dude I had
one of my voices there was someone who's
in transition I think I don't really
yeah I don't Define genders right now
this is 2022. right okay they identified
as they them yeah yeah exactly is that
they have boys one of my voices was
Tommy Lee really they're very distinctly
yeah dude it's like yeah another whippy
[ __ ] yeah dude this is the most distinct
time really and uh yeah I I I I I I
remember wanting to reach out to me like
dude this is
very amazing and he was like it was
he's at a computer station yeah she's
hiding behind your face
again all right dude yeah anybody else
that you like identify ah
personal friends all kinds of them yeah
like
um it was Wild and the thing was that I
loved it dude yeah it's a great drug I
tell you that all the time it is a great
drug but your upside of the high just
immediately goes away after a year or
something like that or two years how
long did you do it uh off and on for a
long time yeah I'd go through phases of
it but but dude everything you were just
telling us was [ __ ] fascinating man
yeah it's very it's very bizarre and
yeah and and almost like as I like asked
that as we were telling all that stories
I almost felt like man I've you know put
TJ in and like like a an uncomfortable
spot but I also was so fascinated by it
you know and I'm gonna talk about it in
my next special I have a a story about
it from this is not happening at Comedy
Central at a show it's called TJ uh
Miller has a seizure but you know now
I'm on medication and have been since
2010 and that's permanent and so and and
what I found out was that I used to be
on Keppra and now I'm on this uh this
medication vimpat which is sort of the
Next Generation but after Keppra after I
changed the medication we were talking
to my neurologist and Kate said so were
there any like side effects that we that
he had from Keppra that that he and the
my doctor was like oh yeah
what do you mean he goes oh yeah
definitely
he has Moon instability impulse control
problems that's a big one I mean name
really sings and Kate was like uh that's
been the problem with exactly and you
know his attitude was like yeah but if
he didn't take it he would die so why
would I tell you oh watch out for these
side effects because that's him other
easy they're dead or he's this guy
and so that was the thing too is nobody
knew that no employer would ever have
been like well he has impulse control
problems so if he's gonna like you know
decide to eat everything in the craft
service table is a joke then get sick
then that's kind of what he's gonna do I
guess we got to just watch out for that
so I never had any of that so there's
another thing that's weird which is like
I think people had this concept of me
being kind of a crazy guy but what they
didn't understand was that was it was a
physical thing it was kind of I was sort
of because when I when I first found out
about the AVM I was filming Yogi Bear 3D
it's a children's movie
the first time he found out about the
adult video
isn't it the AVN Awards yeah
it almost won a bvn award which was uh
bear bear in his videos and uh and so
um and so I was out there and I'm taught
I'm playing Ranger Jones so I'm human
the Bears are CGI I'm out there in New
Zealand so it was a live action movie
yeah it's live action and cartoon hybrid
and it's kind of like Roger Rabbit yeah
and so I'm there and
where I'm I'm depressed me and uh me and
one of the other stars drinking all the
time all the time and it's on the other
side of the world so my schedule so I
just stop sleeping and I started to go
crazy I didn't know it but I was became
obsessed with entanglement puzzles and
which are like you know the Horseshoe
the two horseshoes with the ring and you
gotta try and
so that and then I started to kind of
think my mind had elevated and I was
somehow smarter than everybody else not
like I'm sorry I just had gotten to a
different plane and that I would I would
hear voices I had a tough time going to
sleep
um so I had to listen to Morgan Murphy
who's this comedian and she would talk
and I was sorry and I really started
believing I narrated my own conversation
so I if I was at that point I would come
in and I'd be like all right I'm gonna
start with a compliment to you but I'm
gonna make my way to talk about how his
hoodie seems like a mistake but kind of
helps balance out the two of us and then
I'm going to connect our experiences as
clowns and then we're going to sort of
do a clown bit type thing and I'll I'll
bring that all back to the comment that
you've got so go ahead thank you yeah
and so I would do that and then I
brought these two girls from the
Liverpool England I met them on chat
roulette and I flew them to New Zealand
and they stayed with me uh for the rest
of the movie and it wasn't like a um
sexual thing I I just brought them to
bring a new Fresh perspective to the
movie Set so that everybody could see
the movie Through The Eyes of people
that weren't sort of bogged down by it
because it took forever it was a really
hard movie to shoot everything so it's
doing all this stuff and then I came
back and I did so much [ __ ] nitrous
because at that point I Had a Brain
Hemorrhage a very small bleed so there's
over activity specifically in this part
of my head which is the one that works
on language and all that kind of stuff
and I was going so fast I couldn't sleep
so it's just doing nitrous all the time
all the time morning to night constantly
spending thousands of dollars on Nitro
stock because it costs about a dollar
for a cartridge so it's like the most
expensive High you could ever imagine
last year like what 30 seconds no it's
one hit you just do one cartridge
completely and you were doing like the
uh uh yeah yeah the the whipped cream
dispensers I got really good at like
having two of the dispensers so I'm like
I really like filling them up like going
back I got to a point where I could just
about not breathe in anything except
nitrous oxide oh because yeah if you
hold your breath you get to the
exclusion of oxygen yeah but I would
that's insane that I wasn't doing it
was your goal to what's called fish out
where you lose Consciousness and you're
like flopping around like a fish no I
think that's a major difference between
you and me that's what that's all I
wanted and I would be holding my breath
and holding sucking in more and like
riding around the floor like I'd be mad
at myself like if I couldn't hold my
breath until I lost Consciousness and
flopped around I wouldn't know you're
doing this no but I would find out when
I woke up and I'd be like yes really
dude you are so [ __ ] hardcore no but
I would do the two dispensers at once
and do both them at once or one of the
other but I'd read somewhere that the
oxygen nitrous cut if the Dennis office
gives you is 70 30 nitrous here and so I
would try and kind of gauge that I'd
sort of do it and then yeah regular air
in there yeah it was ridiculous
um but yeah I mean you know it's like a
dollar a cartridge so for an afternoon
you can spend hundreds and hundreds of
dollars it's a bad drug to have
unlimited money yeah you can be able to
buy as much as you want yeah where do
you buy this [ __ ] at at the smoke shops
and then they become dealers and you
kind of go in there and they give you a
better price for the 100 packs and I
would get a case of the 24 boxes
25 per case so it's I think that comes
to 600. yeah exactly and I had I found a
place I could buy them online and Kate
got so mad at me once because she came
and she like was like these two boxes
came from there so heavy and I it took
me forever to get them up and she's like
what are in this and I had forgotten and
I was like I don't know you didn't
forget and she saw it she goes this is
all nitrous oxide and I was like oh yeah
it's for us
right exactly no I mean you know it's I
would also do [ __ ] on nitrous if you're
like in it you start to kind of fall
that's having me instead of fishing out
I would fog out right right I didn't
think it's like foggy right and and you
write regrettable emails yeah for sure
often to myself it's just like go cancel
this order that you said to your white
studio uh yeah I mean it was so I got
back from Yogi Bear 3D was just crushing
cartridges Non-Stop and then I had this
seizure and then another seizure and
when I got there they did a scan and
they're like you have an AVM which is
something we usually find in autopsy so
most people they only find it after
they're dead and um and so I was really
really lucky and it was Cedar Sinai
which is the great Hospital yeah and
they performed surgery they embolized it
and then you know removed it and I I
remember they were like this is in 2010
yeah so that's that's the brain surgery
that was the brain surgery it was like
so do you have a killer scars and under
your hair yeah it's under my hair but
it's yeah I have if you I can't entirely
in a mirror but it's yeah there's a scar
that goes from here all the way down and
he's doing a movie where I shave my head
and look like an insane person because
that would be a good it's a good look
for a villain
um but I I went in and they said look
this we do this surgery but one out of
ten people that do it die
and that's just kind of Statistics we
just have to tell you that it's a 10
fatality rate but if you didn't get the
surgery so I asked I said well will I
still be funny after the surgery and the
doctor was like what he's like what are
you talking about I was like well that's
kind of my livelihood and it's also it's
what I do it's what makes life worth
living for me is making other people
laugh so it was really funny and he's
like
I mean I think so because you're not
really using that part of your brain so
yeah I guess
and okay and I go what happens if I
don't get the surgery he's like well you
probably die when you're in your mid-30s
like 35 and I was like
I'm Gambling Man let's roll the dice you
know and now I'm here and you guys have
better hot sauce for it you know yeah
dude made it made it through that and
then took the Capra
which is that one made me crazy uh
mildly crazy and then I got off of it
because they told me it was elective so
I just stopped taking it for like 11
days man that's this doctor that didn't
tell you about the side effects and said
if you would die if you didn't take it
now you learn it's elective well so
here's what it was he he that this was
before he said so he goes it's elective
his name is Dr Sokol he's the best
neurologist maybe in the world he's
world renowned and he said it's elective
you don't have to take it but you should
and so then I decided five years later
I'm gonna stop taking it and I had a
seizure in like two weeks you know so
then he said to me when he saw me again
he goes okay now you're there's a
percentage of people that they have to
take Keppra and it's a smaller
percentage so you're in the small
percentage that didn't die you're in the
smaller percentage that has to say
Kepler or you will die and so that's
kind of where you are so I actually in
that world I'm like
like a case study because I also become
incredibly successful while still having
this AVM condition and I'm probably I'm
I am I'm the most high profile person
with this type of brain damage
um but it's it's been so good now I mean
the train thing was so awful for so many
reasons but I was so yeah that was like
five years ago yeah it was a while ago
yeah and it's but I was so lucky to find
this cognitive remediation this was you
know the psychologist this
neuropsychologist who said we've really
got to help you learn how to do the
things that other people do without
thinking yeah and so as she's helped me
do that it's gotten a lot better and I
worked for so long
I'm gonna ask you about this I worked
for so long with the brain damage using
alcohol to bring using nitrous oxide to
bring the Mania down also using it to
trigger Mania so that I could get more
and more work done that I had to learn
how to work without feeling like I need
to do this this that I got to stay up I
can't go to sleep I gotta did you feel
like you had to do that when you sort of
got completely sober I had to just put
work aside and just make make sobriety
the only priority for me and I did that
for for really like the first two years
I think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what I've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions my first
books Five star rated on Amazon and I
have no doubt this one will be too so
get the autograph copy right now at
stevo.com
yeah dude